من جهتها قال وزير الدفاع التركي خلوصي
اكار ان العمليه الجويه العسكريه التي
تنفذها بلاده في شمال سوريا والعراق هي
اكبر واجمل من العمليات التي نفذتها في
الفتره الاخيره ودعى الولايات المتحده الى
التوقف عن الدعم الذي تقدمه للمسلحين
الاكراد
المتحده الامريكيه ان حز
ب الاسلامي ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
هما منظمه واحده ونطالب هذه الدول بكل
اسرار بقطع جميع انواع الدعم التي تقدم
الى الارهابيين عمليه المخلب السيف التي
نفذت في شمال كل من سوريا والعراق يوم
الاحد الماضي هي اكبر واجمل واكثر
العمليات الجويه العسكريه فعاليه تم
تنفيذها في الفتره الاخيره وهذه العمليه
استهدفت المواقع على عائده للارهابيين فقط
ودمرت العديده منها